Sadly,
sadly,
we live in a state of fear.
Every day we hear on the news,
on the radio and television and the
newspapers always of war.
We hear of nations hurting each other,
of neighbors hurting each other.
Uh,
families hurting each other and the
children killing each other.
We must learn to live and love each
other before it's too late.
We have to stop.
We have to stop the prejudice.
We have to stop the Haiti.
We have to stop living in fear of our
own neighbors.
I would like all of you now to take the
hand of the person to the left and to
the right of you.
Go ahead right now.
I mean it.
Don't be shy.
Do it cause it starts now to the person
next to you to the left and the right.
I mean it right now.
Go ahead.
Don't be shy.
Do it.
Do it now.
Tell the person,
tell the person next to you that you
care for them.
Tell them that you love them.
This is what makes the difference
together.
We can make a change in the world
We can help to stop racism together.
We can help to stop prejudice.
We can help the world live without fear.
It is our only hope.
Without hope we are lost.
Yeah.